من مخيم جنين معنا مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه
عبد الحفيظ جعوان عبد الحفيظ كيف هي
الصوره من هناك يعني حدت الاشتباكات ما
الذي يحصل بهذه الاثناء بعد كل عمليات
التصعيد الاخيره
في خلفيه الصوره وسوف تسمعين ما زالت
الاشتباكات متواصله حتى هذه اللحظه وبشكل
عنيف جدا يمكن للزميل المصور ان ينتقل هنا
البوابه الشرقيه تقريبا لمخيم جنين دوار
السينما حيث دخلت الجرافات الاسرائيليه من
خرجت من مخيم الجنين وبدات تدخل داخل
المدينه على ما يبدو ان اسرائيل كما فهمنا
والجيش الاسرائيلي تفاجا
خلال عمليته العسكريه داخل المخيم خلال
اليومين
الماضيين بان عدد كبير من المسلحين قد
تمكن من الانسحاب من داخل المخيم ووصل الى
مدينه جنين والى احياء مدينه جنين
وبالتالي اصبح هؤلاء المقابلون
يقومون باطلاق النار
كما تسمعين الان اشتباكات
هي اشتباكات تدور الان بين المقاتلين
الفلسطينيين والقوات الاسرائيليه داخل
مدينه جنين وليس داخل المخيم بعد ان تمكن
هؤلاء المقاتلين من الانسحاب من مخيم
الجنين
والرجوع الى المدينه ويقومون باطلاق النار
على القوات التي تحاصر بعض الاحياء داخل
المخيم وبالتالي منذ ظهيره هذا اليوم ونحن
نشهد اشتباكات عنيفه جدا داخل المدينه
وداخل المخيم ايضا هذا يتزامن مع
مع ايضا طائرات بدون طيار التي لم تفارق
الاجواء بتاتا وايضا مع قوات عسكريه يعني
تواصل جولاتها وعمليات التجريف وعمليات
الدهم والمطارده داخل المخيم وداخل
المدينه بشكل عام عبد الحفيظ يعني بموازات
هذه الصوره الوضع الانساني داخل
المخيم وداخل المدينه بما ان المقاتلين
انتقلوا الى هنا كيف هي الصوره وماذا ايضا
عن حركه النزوح
والنزوح
وعلى ما يبدو ان ايضا المشهد بالنسبه
لاسرائيل يعني
كان محرجا على الصعيد الدولي بشكل كبير
وبالتالي وذكر الناس بموضوع التهجير
وموضوع النكبه وما الى ذلك وبالتالي لم
يكرر ولكن بالنسبه لمشهد الان المواجهات
كما هو المشهد داخل مخيم جنين كما هو
المشهد في المدينه وان كان الان المواجهات
في المدينه اعنف بكثير من المواجهات التي
تجري في المخيم بسبب وجود عدد كبير من
المسلحين كما قلت الذين خرجوا وتمكنوا من
الخروج من المخيم باتجاه المدينه الجرافات
الاسرائيليه عندما جرفت محيط المخيم
ونسفت البنيه التحتيه وارادت محاصره
المسلحين بناء على هدف الخطه الاسرائيليه
الاساسي وهو اما اعتقال او او تصفيه
المطاردين وجدت وتفاجات العديد من الانفاق
الموجوده في بعض الحارات وبعض الاماكن
وعلى ما يبدو ان المسلحين استخدموا تلك
الانفاق في الفرار من داخل المخيم الى
خارجه ويقومون الان يعني بالاتيان على شكل
مجموعات واطلاق النار على القوات
الاسرائيليه
ويعني البنيه العسكريه للفصائل الموجوده
داخل المخيم ما هي المناطق والمراكز او
النقاط التي استهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
بساعات الماضيه وعن ماذا نتحدث بالساعات
المقبله بهذا الصدد
بالنسبه للمناطق والنقاط كان هناك يعني
يعني بعض
البيوت وبعض في مسجد الانصار مثلا كان
بالاساس كان كان هدفا لغارات جويه ثم
الاقتحام بعض البيوت لمن تعتبرهم باسرائيل
مطلوبين
وغيرهم كانت هذه كلها اهداف بالنسبه
لاسرائيل ايضا كان هناك عمليات اعتقال
واسعه في صفوف الاهالي ولكن من كان يشعر
من الشبان انه مطلوب وانه مطارد تمكن من
من الفرار من داخل المخيم الى خارجه
الحقيقه حتى الهدف الرئيسي الاساسي تغير
خلال اليومين
الماضيين وهذا كان ملاحظا الهدف الاساسي
كان العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه كما صرح
في البدايه بانه القضاء على تواجد المسلح
للفلسطينيين وانهاء ظاهره السلاح في مخيم
جنين ومدينه جنين والهدف الفرعي كان هو
يعني
ضبط بعض المختبرات الخاصه بتصنيع
المتفجرات البدائيه ولكن عندما ايقن الجيش
ان موضوع
يعني انهاء ظاهره التسليح وظاهره المسلحين
في المخيم هي يعني مستحيله لانها هذا ليست
تنظيما عسكريا كاملا او او مركزي ليس لديه
قائد ولا اجنحه وما الى ذلك ناشطون
فلسطينيون يعني يفرون من خلال المخيم
وسيعودون ربما في اليوم او في الساعات
التي تتلو خروج الجيش الاسرائيلي من
المخيم تغير الان الهدف واصبح الهدف
الرئيسي هو
تفكيك هذه المختبرات الخاصه بتصنيع
العبوات الناسفه وعلى ما يبدو ان نتنياهو
الان امامها حرج كبير لانه بات على علم
تماما انه في اللحظه التي سيخرج منها من
جنين ومن مخيم جنين سوف نشاهد العشرات من
المسلحين الفلسطينيين وسط المخيم يرفعون
اسلحتهم ويهتفون انهم انتصروا هذا سيكون
محرج جدا لنتني اهو وبالتالي ربما يحاول
يعني تصعيد هذه العمليه العسكريه
لضمان يعني اسكات المعارضه له في الحكومه
شكرا لك يا عبد الحفيظ جعوان مراسل
العربيه حدثنا من مخيم جنين